we got 44 ambulances 22-mile are
supposed to be running we got 17 18 on
any night because they're broken light
rail
[Music]
Detroit which has seen its population
cut in half since 1950 is home to an
estimated 90,000 vacant houses you can
look at the empty buildings the great
architect and you say man is this a
waste next year construction is
scheduled to begin on a 500 million
dollar light rail line up woodward
avenue that will go from downtown
detroit to the edge of the suburbs it's
not a wacky Birkenstock idea it's a real
you know it's a real idea Murray Donegan
is a michigan state representative from
Royal Oak a suburb of Detroit what do
you think will happen to those vacant
warehouses when there's a really dynamic
really dynamic public transportation
system on where Transportation Secretary
Ray LaHood was in town in July to pledge
federal support for the project and to
announce that the city of Detroit is on
the move
frequently called the most cosmopolitan
city of the Midwest Detroit today stands
at the threshold of a bright new future
the inner city is becoming an exciting
place to live convenient to shops
offices and the most modern of school
we have the opportunity to rebuild an
entire urban center which for me as a
person with a master's degree in
landscape architecture and regional
planning that is truly exciting the
applied skills of planners idea men
organizers builders Detroiters who
welcome and respond to challenges if the
light rail system would come on in 2016
as planned they would be trains to
nowhere
you simply cannot have a Manhattan
without a subway but it's not the subway
that built Manhattan Manhattan built the
subway light rail is not going to build
a troy we are at the proposed terminus
of said light rail charlie Ladakh is a
Pulitzer Prize winning reporter for the
Detroit News who's getting out of the
car parking it here leaving the car and
driving downtown this is what it looks
like during rush hour on Woodward
it's gonna take a huge effort to educate
the public about the system whatever the
system is that's going to be built to
educate them to help them understand the
value of public transportation you know
this is light rail they're talking about
from here to downtown five hundred
million dollars is that the number one
thing we need right now in Detroit we
can all drive our cars to go to the
football game in to the basketball games
and all that or we can have other ways
for people to get to the sports stadiums
we need better police the schools need
improving the garbage pickup the better
ambulance service but it drink more than
two beers and out two beers and I'll get
on the street and I'll get arrested for
drunk driving and ruin my life people
really don't want to do that anymore
that we got a lot a lot of other things
we could be spending that money on so we
have a limited pool of money right so
what you're saying is we only there's
only so much money in the world ever no
obviously that's not true if we wanted
to build a new if that was the case then
if we wanted to build a new school and
roll up for instance we'd say we cannot
build another school in Royal Oak
because there's because we only have so
much money money did anybody ask you for
a light rail whoo
what we find is that people like to get
from point A to point B as quickly as
possible so the bus system particularly
in cities like Detroit is going to be
far more effective at serving the needs
of the low-income then developing a
transit system and the city of Detroit
already has a light rail the people
[Music]
the People Mover is a circulator within
the downtown some people think of it as
a joke others ride it all the time to
get from Greektown to the baseball game
you know to the football game a building
fell on the tracks
there is no discernible impact on travel
and it was out of commission for months
they've nice to have it when you've got
a festival and you got a baseball game
but people moving downtown to be close
to the people mover
Detroit has to recenter itself in the
basics low crime low taxes make it a
business climate that supports
investment in households once that
vibrancy begins to come back pop perhaps
in the future rail will make sense but
right now I don't see it let's have a
true accounting of what the problem is
here let's put the money in that and
then God willing build some cool rails
build some swimming pools write the city
on the Straits welcomes you to share
that vision as it continues to plan to
build and yes to dream
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]